i need a granola bar i need a little bit
of a boost
too many
too many slip ups already
too many fumbling of the words
okay grunfeld land
on chess cube they're calling this after
d5 the anglo-grunfeld defense
all right
whatever they say
um
what do you do here
chop a knight and then c5
let's do it
okay c5 pawn you know you want to play
or should i just say c pawn come on c
pawn you know you want to play right
there
okay
let's go knight i'm not going to fiend
cat on my bishop
what should i be doing here i'm just
going to go with a
small little setup my opponent does have
a majority in the center
very easily it'll turn into a two on one
and currently that's what we're working
with
two on one bishop e7 or maybe queen c7
is gonna be
a better idea
there's gonna be some fire placed on a
b7
hmm interesting
you know what i think already that that
was a mistake to take on this square
before my opponent throws this pawn up
they played this pawn up here then
there's less worry i would have on this
diagonal
however we might jump right into end
game
territory
and
in in an end game i think maybe these
two could become
pretty good
queen a5 or chop and then queen here
i don't like how quickly this rook could
maybe make use of c7 in a more
simplified end game
and that's that's the direction we're
going here
we're really close to getting into that
type of an end game
how about i play here
and let's see what white wants to do
take with my queen i really want to get
my queen bishop out it's a big dummy
right now
big dummy
actually
this might be all right
oh man so i'm already seeing an
improvement that was uh i think a bit
foolish to be taking the knight right
there maybe it is a line or something
but i think there's
to to allow white to say you know what
they have a stronger center now they
could be playing over here and i might
as well just do it right here and
actually the king has to come out
otherwise this pawn is dropping
now
where does my king want to go where's my
bishop on a go actually i think right
here
is the way to go
get that bishop out
and
now i think i start to be better
let's go rook
two to one majority my king is going to
be on e7 my rooks are going to be
doubled let's get connected there's no
need to castle
remember that
there's no need to castle right there
and
i play here just not here
right here thank you
rook here there could be night there and
i can't move that knight
pawn push or knight to a5 is my thought
i think this is
maybe
best
no no no no no no
i'm gonna do this
and i think f6 is a move i want to play
f6 before i decide to move my knight off
of the c6 square
let's go with it
i think i can actually sneak up a bit
more with my king
right here
i think it'll turn out to be safe
or will it we're going to see about that
king d6 end games
tight game so far
uh where's my knight wanna go
a5 most likely or maybe here right now
fixing this pawn on a light square and a
resulting end game with opposite with
the same color bishops i could uh stand
better
i think i want to do that
or maybe not
pawn push
knight here
scary time it's a scary time to be
playing the black pieces right now
because you're down on time
and you don't know what to do
knight e5 e5
runaway scared
knight here pawn push king e7
not liking that rook c7 nonsense i think
i need to secure my king position takes
knight takes
ah i could do that but what if pawn push
then i just uh
then i just deal with it
okay hopefully this could become a
target down the line we're gonna see i
invested a lot of
clock seconds right here okay my knight
wants to play here
the rooks are most likely coming off or
are they do i want to let them come off
i better make up my mind
oh there might be a fort guruski right
here one day
maybe i should let my opponent think
about that
oh
they're having something else to say
there
okay here's the plan
take this rook keep one pair of rooks on
the board and i think my knight
wants to go for a slight repositioning
fortunately i have this square covered
otherwise the rook is going to give me a
beating and a half
knight c5 i'm having flashbacks of a
game that i played against to gm where
they did this to me
a knight on c5 eventually
rook up and over if pawn push here maybe
rook up and over and g3 could be
targeted otherwise i get an active rook
on the h file
all right let's go
activity
activity here
two to one majority my opponent does
have this as an asset but
be cautious
are there any entry points for that rook
i'm not seeing it
play there no
actually right now i am going to
say you know what
it's just trade rooks
and i'm going to try and win this end
game let's see if i could do it
i have 42 tickarooski's left
to trade or not to trade is a big big
big question
ah let's trade here we go and now that's
actually turning out to be a problem
this pawn should not have moved
i think i could get in g or b5 a5 b4
kick the bit can kick the king back
excuse me
but first things first let me do this i
don't want the king to be able to play
here after i have established a pawn on
the b4 square
i do not want to trade bishops because
this is
incredibly
powerful in just a king and pawn end
game
so i need to be really accurate and i do
not know if i'll be able to do that with
the time remaining my opponent did
throw out a draw offer but i'm going to
try to win this
i'm going to play actually a5 first if
allowed maybe bishop here no bishop
there is allowing that
let me do this i don't want to do that
and then maybe trap my bishop again i'm
not going for this
i don't care about that trade
let's stop this pawn push i don't want
to deal with it
pawn push pawn push
pawn push
26
let's go now this is a threat
how do i capture i think i go with this
because the pawn is harder to track down
now he's a he's an outside pass pun and
in fact
back up i think check i don't i don't
know if i i don't know if i could catch
it
let's go pawn
hopefully i could throw my opponent in
a tough position here
oh
i gotta come back
i gotta come back with my king i think
okay wait what's the what's the plan
here
oh they're dropping their pawns now
9.5 seconds though
pac-man mode
pac-man mode engaged okay now oh wait
wait wait wait
let me do this just to stop any pre-move
stuff
i could have fell for that actually
very easily that pawn should have stayed
on h2
it should have definitely stayed on h2
now there's a an issue here
right without a doubt there's an issue
watch out for stalemate
get that out of there
and then push this guy push this guy
push this guy just want to clear the way
that's actually me
okay
oh it shouldn't have went down like that
towards the end
good game
down to the wire
oh
man
tight game
really nice first time playing i believe
against uh dan the man triple seven
tight game i think the first suggestion
i have is for myself
i don't know about taking the knight
like that i think i should be doing
something else like c5
i don't know because the this pawn
didn't move just yet it's more typical
to capture on this square once
threatened with the four
e4's played if the bishop is going to
really come out in this direction
maybe the c4 square is more vulnerable
somehow actually that didn't make a
whole lot of sense but anyhow i think c5
right here let me emphasize at least one
clear point i should do this instead of
building my opponent's center and
allowing them to know
um well you know maybe they can play on
the b file and have the bishop over here
and coordinate on b7
so
and
so we end up with this huh
is there something better
and by something better i wonder is
there a need
for white to actually play d4 at this
very moment
it could be played in and play that on
the next turn
if you play it now then this could
become a
a problem i think i think i do better i
think black does better to be
exchanging off another pair of minor
pieces but
i think you could be avoiding that right
just castle
and then you won't have to contend with
the bishop b4 move
you you um you don't allow one
additional option that i'll have here
if you just castle first
because right now i'm i'm i'm torn
between these two squares for my bishop
but as soon as this exchange comes about
this is another appealing move
if you just castle
uh there's a good chance that i'll
already make a move with my bishop and
then after you play d4 if i take you
recapture if i'm playing bishop b4 well
i'm losing some time correct
so i think castle is maybe a slight
improvement there just trying to be real
technical about things and i don't know
if a3 is even necessary
actually it is because you'd be dropping
that pawn
or some something has to be done here
maybe maybe you take
you could take me that's another one
i don't know if there's a big difference
between having the pawn on a3 or a2
nothing's uh jumping out at me so we
entered this
phase of the game
and
these moves start to become an issue
as soon as it was played i was thinking
about bishop versus bishop ending and
maybe being able to target the e4 pawn
i don't know i think that this was still
an even position
do you have to be cautious because this
is exactly where i would want my pawns
in a resulting king bishop and pawn end
game
and
is it worthwhile for you to stop this uh
pawn advance
now i think i think actually rook up and
over could be a problem
so i think how you played it is fine get
the knight get remove remove the glue it
was real it took my opponent very little
time to recognize the the value of a
knight being positioned on c5 getting
rid of it as soon as possible is a good
idea keeping the h file closed with g4
good once again and this right here you
can do without
it's just one potent one additional
target that i would have
um
so you could do without h3
and i don't know about uh this end game
here
right here
i don't know what i have this is as best
as best i can do in fact i might be
losing right here in fact
well i don't know
this is tough there's still a lot of
calculation in this end game and i
neither of us had time to really work it
all out
uh you could be playing pawn push and i
have to come back
and then you could be playing
well now that actually isn't working out
pawn push i play here i was thinking you
can move your bishop and support this d7
advance but you don't have that
available so that's not working if you
do d6 i play here and then king c5 grab
the pawn and then come back here and try
and go after these guys so pawn push
isn't good just then
my king is in a spot now and i think you
have to come back
without a doubt this is the best move
you can't allow my bishop to get here
so if you did do that
i'm kind of stuck i think
unless no you know what i think i could
actually run this guy
i could run after this f3 pawn
um
interesting now actually let me look at
this a bit closer because i think
there's an important piece of advice to
offer here
um if you come back here and i believe
you are needing to do that
uh there's just too many pawns i could
be gobbling up once i get at this guy
so i think after bishop to e2
i run with my king here and go after
this guy
king
d4
and i'm not sure what you even do at
your king i don't know
i guess you just kind of have to shuffle
king king to b1
king here
and
the bishop has to play here i guess i
grabbed this pawn i think this is
actually losing
yeah you know it might just turn out to
be losing and that earlier point that i
thought i would have was regarding you
know where i should be placing my bishop
to prevent this pond from advancing
and maybe it is actually still a point
that i could uh be making i think it
still is lost for white in this endgame
or if we are at it at this position i
think having the bishop
maintain itself along this diagonal to
prevent this d7 push is better than
let's say having it on this diagonal
because i'm foreseeing something like
the bishop a white bishop maybe somehow
getting to f5
and then chasing my own bishop
off this diagonal and then maybe maybe
pushing it away or something
although i guess
i guess it would still be all right like
if i had my bishop here to stop this
pawn from advancing to d7
and it was challenged with your bishop
on f5 i could come back
to e8 um
so i don't know this this turns out to
be tough
this end game right here that h3 move i
could do without but i don't know if i
should have been able to escort those uh
that two on one majority like
like that i had a good king position
once the rooks were off
i guess there really wasn't a whole lot
that could be done about that one
but uh these are these are moves to at
least be giving a second thought to
right here when it came time to be
pushing in the center
knowing that with just a single file
being opened
uh the likelihood that both sets of
rooks will come off the board is that
much greater
so to start to already in other words
visualize an end game
where the rooks aren't on the board and
the pawn structure starts to become
a bigger issue and having pawns fixed on
light squares
probably staying away from
that positioning of your ponds is a good
idea
okay
good